[Música]
[Aplausos]
decimos hace un rato
que la actual forma de gestionar
nuestras organizaciones nuestras
empresas es claramente mejorable
permitiendo que empiece haciendo alguna
pregunta
trabajáis más ahora después de la crisis
que nos estamos esforzando el doble
estamos mejorando los resultados con
esto ha aumentado la calidad de nuestro
trabajo
segunda pregunta estáis aprovechando
esta crisis realmente para reiniciar nos
está aprovechando la organización y la
empresa esta crisis para reiniciar lo
que consideramos necesario
y tercera pregunta estamos siendo
sinceros hablamos hace un rato de verdad
incómoda'
estamos siendo sinceros con este
reinicio
nos gusta decir y nos gusta pensar que
los problemas complejos tengan
soluciones sencillas yo esto le llamo
populismo los problemas complejos tienen
soluciones complejas
para abordar estas soluciones se
necesita un enfoque sistémico para
mejorar el modelo de gestión empresarial
necesitamos un modelo una solución
completa que afecte y que involucre a
tres grandes actores empresa
trabajadores y gobiernos
voy a realizar una muy breve propuesta
para cada uno de estos tres actores
el primero los trabajadores
seleccionamos a trabajadores
probablemente por sus conocimientos
también los seleccionamos por sus
competencias por sus experiencias
creo que hay que añadir dos cosas más
después de esta crisis
una parte la inteligencia vital
qué es esto fijaros ahí siempre digo que
hay dos tipos de personas en todas las
organizaciones están los plomos aquellos
a los que te pegas a ellos y te hunde en
esta empresa es muy mala tu jefe no vale
para nada él lleva diez años aquí le
quedan otros diez años estos plomos te
unen directamente
y después por otra parte están los
corchos
esto es corcho está sin flotar resulta
que la misma empresa y es otra realidad
completamente distinta
independientemente de que creo que
tenemos que ser más corchos también
debéis de poner algún corcho en vuestra
vida
por otra parte
las empresas creo que siguen buscando
personas obedientes
y creo que esto no funciona hoy en día
para reiniciarse necesitamos ciertas
dosis de inconformismo
y finalmente entiendo inteligencia vital
también como ser autocrítico con uno
mismo estos tres ejes forman parte de lo
que yo considero una forma nueva de
trabajar
hacer corcho ser autocrítico y ser
inconformista y dejarlos de ser
obedientes
y la otra parte la otra faceta que creo
que necesitan nuestros trabajadores
es la inteligencia de negocio
necesitamos personas en cualquier puesto
de la organización que no solo vean su
puesto
que sepan ver el negocio desde cualquier
ámbito necesitamos personas que además
sepan vender yo soy profesor y creo que
tengo necesidad de vender donde trabajo
y permitiendo un pequeño paréntesis
llevo diez años está en la universidad y
de veras que estoy muy agradecido el
trato que he recibido ha sido
maravilloso es verdad que tenemos una
serie de metodologías y una serie de
guías docentes que marcan un poco mi
docencia pero en ningún momento me han
obligado a decir aquellas cosas que
tenía que decir he tenido la libertad de
castidad absoluta y me han hecho
disfrutar muchísimo esta universidad así
que muchas gracias
y por último además de de personas que
conozcan el negocio y personas que sepan
vender
necesitamos
que ante cualquier decisión y en
cualquier puesto de trabajo
pensemos en términos de costes y
beneficios y cualquier decisión que
tenemos es que tomemos ya sea yo
profesor cualquier persona que piense en
esto por tanto la inteligencia de
negocio tiene otras tres patas conocer
negocio vender
y además analizar desde punto de vista
económico
a los gobiernos que era la segunda parte
vemos a los trabajadores vamos a hablar
de los gobiernos
es evidente que nuestro estilo de vida
necesita una seguridad laboral
a todos nos gusta tener una casa en
propiedad e hipotecarnos 20 años
a todos nos gusta mucho tener familia y
que estos hijos tengan lo mejor posible
y por tanto esto solo nos proporciona si
nos dan una seguridad y una estabilidad
laboral y yo no quiero que esto que
renunciemos a esto y que con este
reinicio tendremos que renunciar a esta
parte pero también hay que entender a
las empresas las empresas necesitan
flexibilidad nosotros necesitamos
seguridad y la empresa decida
flexibilidad no es posible hoy en día
que obligamos a un empresario a
contratar a una persona para desarrollar
exclusivamente una función y que si
quiere cambiar esa función tenga que
firmar un nuevo contrato y una serie de
trámites que creo que no hacen posible
este reinicio
por tanto los gobiernos deben de nadar
en un marco que podemos llamar de
flexiseguridad
que permita dar un empleo incluso de por
vida porque yo creo que hay empleos de
por vida espero que un yo lo sea
y además que permitan que te puedan
cambiar de puesto y que te pueden
cambiar de funciones
última parte hemos hablado trabajadores
hemos hablado empresas vamos a hablar
ahora de trabajadores de gobiernos vamos
a hablar ahora de empresas
utiliza una frase una palabra que lo
utilizaba en inglés porque me gusta es
el post céntrico que nos ocurre en las
empresas que seguimos poniendo al jefe
en el centro
les pedimos además que deleguen que
dejen hacer que sean conciliadores se
gasta muchísimo tiempo en supervisar
invertimos muchísimo tiempo en controlar
podemos trabajar cuando nuestro jefe no
nos vigila sabemos hacer esto
creo que ha llegado un momento de
reinventarnos dentro de las
organizaciones tenemos que ir a
organizaciones duales cuando mejore
trabajado ha sido en red
nunca trabajó bien con un jefe la
autoridad yo personalmente no la llevo
bien y en cambio trabajó muy bien en red
creo que tenemos que ir a ese espacio
anual entre jerarquía y red
creo que si nos reiniciamos en este
sentido vamos a mejorar todos
último concepto que quería hablaros
queridos del cliente fijaros
creo que estamos orientados desde mi
punto de vista excesivamente al cliente
diría que nos hemos pasado
la orientación es tan alta que de verdad
que si el cliente supiese lo que
realmente hacemos para producir o para
dar el servicio que ellos piden no nos
comprarían
a estos eslóganes de los años 80 que
todavía siguen vigentes del cliente
tiene razón
del cliente lo primero
creo que han hecho que otros actores de
este sistema sufran por ejemplo los
proveedores
os habéis planteado vosotros que nuestra
nómina la cobra 6 a 120 días lo que está
aquí se puede imaginar lo que supone
ingresar por su trabajo 120 días después
de haberlo merecido
para cerrar
quería plantearnos una pregunta los
grandes cambios yo creo que no los
elegimos
levantar la mano por favor aquellos que
hayáis elegido esta crisis
si elegimos cómo reaccionamos ante
cambio
fijaros por ello valoro mucho más a
aquellas personas que saben encontrar la
motivación en aquello que les toca
esto es una cualidad impresionante y en
cambio no valoro tanto a aquellas
personas que han logrado trabajar en lo
que su pasión
yo no elegí ser profesor yo no elegí ser
emprendedor
y creo que logrado y solo con esfuerzo
que ambas cosas me gusten y por eso el
valor tanto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]